التحدي الذي يواجهنا في الحرب هو القضاء على التهديد وليس
تثبيطه ونعرف كيفية القضاء على فيليز
إن Tyror أكثر صعوبة بالنسبة لنا مع فكرة Unra هذه
أصل فكرة أن رينات تلد آخر
والمزيد من الإرهابيين بكل أنواع الأساليب وهذا مستحيل
سوف ننتصر في الحرب إذا لم ندمر
أونرا وهذه الإبادة يجب أن تبدأ على الفور، فهذا لا يحدث
من المناسب الحديث عن اليوم التالي لليوم الذي هو الآن
وعلينا أن نعمل على الاعتراف بالتهديدات
هذه تماما أو أننا سوف تفوت النافذة
لقد كانت الفرص هنا عدة مرات بالفعل
لقد فعلنا ذلك، وفي هذا السياق هناك مجموعتان من الإجراءات
أن نتمكن من المضي قدما في يوم من الأيام هو الموقف
لدولة إسرائيل ونارا والدول المساهمة فيها
والثاني هو الموقف تجاه سكان الشوناري الفلسطينيين
الخدوش في بعض الأحيان بطريقة شبه مشروعة جديرة بالاهتمام
للتعامل مع أونرا بنفسها، دعونا نتذكر أنها كذلك
عمل
هنا في الأراضي التي احتلتها إسرائيل عام 1967 بموجب الطلب
إسرائيل للقيام بذلك هو ما جلبت
نفس الفم الذي يمكن لإسرائيل أن تطلبه منها الآن
للتوقف وفي نفس الوقت تجميد وضع اللاجئ
التي توزعها بسخاء شديد لأنها إجرامية
هناك امتحانات دولية بشهادات
لا يمكن نقل Unra، يجب إلغاؤها
في الإثم يجب أن يذهبوا إلى سلة المهملات من يستحق أن يذهب
وسوف تحقق مما إذا كان ضرب cr إذا كان يأتي حقا
له